bonsoir linda g skin merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france qu'est-ce
que vous retiendrez vous de cette
journée de mémoire de ce forum de la
shoah aujourd'hui c'était une journée
très émotionnel je pense que tout change
c'était la présence du président
allemand monsieur talent ailleurs qui a
déclaré qui a téléchargé par la
culpabilité des actes des nazis contre
les bulls ont lancé une bénédiction et
break
l'idée que le président alliances 75 ans
que la libération de suite soit à
jérusalem est par les pr
et bien c'est très touchant pour
beaucoup de personnes ça vous semble
indispensable ces forums c'est devoir de
mémoire à chaque anniversaire c'est
important pour ne pas répéter l'histoire
je pense effectivement que c'est
important de marquer l'anniversaire
important le 25.5 en appelant le 75e
importante également car les survivants
de l'holocauste supporter kényan de ce
qui s'est passé et riez et d'ici
quelques années il n'y en aura plus
aujourd'hui il y en a encore
tout ce sont 15 minutes d'ici à quelques
années il ne restera presque plus ce qui
est à la riposte
maintenant je pense que c'est important
de se souvenir car nous le voyons dans
le monde entier
il ya de plus en plus de voix qui disent
que le low cost n'a jamais eu lieu que
c'était une invention que c'est un
complot juif
avec ces célébrations et mémorielle on
permet de rappeler et n'ont que cela à
eux et avec un peu de chance toute forme
de génocide de quelque peuple que ce
soit n'aura pas lieu une étude ifop 1
qui date de 2008 en france indique que
chez nous en tout cas un français sur
dix ignorer l'existence de la shoah ça
paraît incroyable
est ce que ça vous semble crédible ce
type d'étude et et est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui a lieu également dans
d'autres pays
il faut sont inquiétés parce que c'est
effectivement un sujet de préoccupation
et aux etats unis également je pense
qu'encore plus de personnes ont jamais
entendu parler de la shoah
on ne pense pas que six millions de
juifs ont été tués parce que tout ça a
été inventé de toutes pièces difficiles
qu'on suit l'histoire lorsqu'on connaît
l'histoire que cela soit possible
mais les gens pensent ce qu'ils veulent
croire ce genre de forum des halles avec
49 chefs d'état et des hauts
représentants
ça permet d'attirer l'attention sur cela
avec autant de chefs d'état réunis à un
endroit alors forcément l'attention est
retourné sur cet endroit
chose qui est vraie et les historiens de
l'holocauste le tiercé qui devrait avoir
plus d'éducation fondant comme à fin mai
le tour de la shoah images des dizaines
d'imams deux frères musulmans tombés
notamment en arabie saoudite seront
visitées le commando suite justement
c'était ma question pour vous il ne
s'agit pas que de la responsabilité des
gouvernements pour introduire évidemment
ces programmes dans les livres
d'histoire c'est déjà finalement le cas
mais c'est le devoir de finalement tout
citoyen et
et de tout responsable de quelque
religion que ce soit de ce devoir de
mémoire notamment sur la shoah et pour
les autres génocides évidemment des
autres peuples
en israël beaucoup de lycéens se rendent
à auschwitz afin de voir de leurs
propres yeux les camps de concentration
vers la fin de leur cursus
il passe plusieurs mois à étudier le low
cost
je pense qu'il est très important que
tomber sur 24 et il faut combiner une
fois qu'on voit de ses propres yeux
cela rappelle et cela rend impossible
d'imaginer l'ampleur de cette terreur il
ya également des musées sur le low cost
en amandes entières se trouve le
mémorial et un musée extraordinaire avec
des centaines et des centaines d'acteurs
fact de films de photographies
c'est une autre façon je les avais un
tenir là bas la loire et d'essayer de
comprendre je pense que toutes les
nations et sauf que l'ena view je me
dope s'engageait et dire qu'elle n'en
diront pas et c'est le cas que faire en
pratique le jeu ne devrait pas permettre
le génocide de quelque peuple que ce
soit sur gand d'élus locaux se souvient
plus jamais simple et beaucoup de
dirigeants d'aujourd'hui mais monsieur
netanyahou l'asis président américain en
vacances le président macron ils ont
tous dit plus jamais ça
je pense que les millions de doit se
rappeler cela est causé la mort d'un
coup deux innocents vous vous excitez
bayemi netanyahu qui a aussi fait un
petit peu de politiques en critiquant
durement l'iran le régime tyrannique
est-ce que selon vous c'était le moment
opportun pour ce message là
ce que j'ai 100 questions intéressantes
certaines personnes disaient qu'ils
n'étaient pas d'user des trucs politique
qu'il est aujourd'hui
je pense que le premier ministre voit ce
qui se passe en iran et les efforts
iraniens pour acquérir la bombe
nucléaire comme le résultat direct de
l'holocauste iront en tant que régime
dont le low cost
je pense que pour lui c'est une menace
existentielle envers israël et c'est
pour cela qu'il a ses permis d'être
politique tension de secours
certes il ya eu des critiques et
certaines personnes m'ont dit il a déjà
dit cela plusieurs reprises et peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui n'aurait pas dû merci
beaucoup en tout cas linda gray style de
nous avoir apporté votre analyse après
cette journée la réunion tous ses
dirigeants à jérusalem pour le forum de
la shoah merci beaucoup à vous